>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Good afternoon.
Welcome to the Library of
Congress Literacy Awards program
to recognize best practices
in reading promotion.
I'm Kathryn Mendenhall, Director
of National Programs here
at the Library of Congress,
which is in the National
and International Outreach
Service Unit.
The Center for the Book,
which administers the
Literacy Awards program is also
organizational in this service unit.
You are all here to demonstrate
how your impassioned work can be
replicated and shared with others
to achieve the extraordinary
success we're celebrating today.
Our hope is that new
partnerships will be formed,
new dialogue will be held, not
just with the Library of Congress,
but among yourselves
and with each other
so that you can see what others
are doing and use their ideas
to make your programs even better.
It's really a unique
opportunity to have all
of you here today from near and far.
Since its founding in 1800,
the Library of Congress's
mission has been one
of disseminating knowledge.
Thirty years ago, in transmitting
a report to Congress in response
to a congressional
resolution authorizing a study
of the changing role of the book
in the future, what the Librarian
of Congress at the time,
who was Daniel Boorstin,
stated in his transmittal
letter is applicable today.
He said, "What we do
about books and reading
in the next decades will crucially
affect our citizen's opportunities
for enlightenment and
self-improvement,
their ability to share in the
wisdom and delights of civilization
and their capacity for
intelligent self-government.
There could be no more appropriate
effort to fulfill the hopes
of our nation's founders nor
any more appropriate celebration
of the Bicentennial
of our constitution
than to aim to abolish illiteracy."
The Literacy Awards
benefactor, David M. Rubenstein,
established these awards
with the idea the
by recognizing outstanding literacy
efforts both in the United States
and abroad, public
attention will be drawn
to the continuing need
for literacy services.
Mr. Rubenstein was unable
to be here with us today,
but he sends his hardy
congratulations
and gratitude to you.
As you all know, it is difficult
to learn if one cannot read.
So, I too applaud you
and congratulate you
for making it possible for people
to reach their full potential
by learning through reading.
Thank you.
I'll now turn the program
over to John Cole,
Director of the Center for the Book.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Kathryn.
Well, this is a big
day for literacy.
Before we proceed with the
best practices part of this,
I'm going to give you the --
today is the official
day of the announcement
of not only our literacy prizes,
but of the best practice winners.
And I do want to say that we
have this year a two part event
with both the prize winners
and the best practices people.
And today is best practices day.
But it's only polite and proper
that I mention the three other
prize winners and announce
that they are going to be
the prize winners for 2015.
The three other prizes are the
David Rubenstein Prize named
for our funder and the
winner is First Book,
which is a local organization.
[ Applause ]
The American prize, which
goes to an organization based
in the United States goes
to United Through Reading.
Let's give them a round of applause.
[ Applause ]
And the international
prize goes to Beanstalk,
which was a best practices
prize winner last year.
They are not here.
They are in England, but let's
give them a round of applause.
[ Applause ]
And we do have representatives
from First Book and I think United
Through Reading here, Alison
Morris from First Book,
would you wave your hand and
take a round of applause?
[ Applause ]
And Kristin Driscoll, are here
from United Through Reading?
There she is.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
So, we congratulate you and
we are eager to continue
to celebrate your good work
as well as the good work
of our wonderful best practices
people who are with us today.
One more brief announcement.
We had a meeting this morning of the
Library of Congress Advisory Board
for our Literacy Awards and several
of the members are
here this afternoon.
And I'd like to have them
stand when I announce them
and let's hold our applause for
the end, after they all sit down.
The first one on my list is
Karen Lots from Candlewick.
Karen. They may be seated
close together for all I know.
I'm guessing.
Lesley Farmer who is from
California State, somewhere.
Lesley, are you close by?
There you are.
Sorry. Karen Ristow
[assumed spelling]
who is actually the Chair
of our American prize.
I know you're here, Karen.
Yes, you are.
Laura Bailet from Nemours Bright
Start who is on our board.
Cynthia Hearn Dorfman.
Cynthia is here.
Susan Hildreth is not here.
She was -- joined us by telephone
this morning for the meeting.
Linda Bird Johnson Robb is here.
Wonderful advocate for
children's literacy.
Lynda. And, finally, Christie
Vilsack from U.S. Aid is here.
And Michael Suarez is here.
Michael -- some place.
I think. There he is.
Sorry. It's bright up here.
And Michael Trucano from World Bank.
Let's give them all
a round of applause.
[ Applause ]
I must say this board has
helped formulate the program.
We're now in our third year.
This is our third round of awards.
We look forward to the next two
years and we hope much longer.
But Mr. Rubenstein has graciously
funded this program for five years.
And one of the results
we want you to pick up,
if you didn't get coming in,
it's this Best Practices program
which has each of your organizations
in it and we want you to use it
in every way to promote
yourselves, to promote literacy,
to promote your connection
to the Library of Congress.
This is what this program
is all about.
And you represent it from
all parts of the world.
Thank you.
We're now going to
present the certificates
to the best practices people
and to do the presenting,
I'm pleased to call to the podium
Guy Lamolinara who is the Center
for the Book's Communication
Officer.
I will present the certificates.
Our photographer is ready.
Are you ready?
Well, here we go.
Guy?
Thanks, John.
I'll read the names in
alphabetical order by organization.
So, could you please come up
and accept your award from John?
The first person is Basara
Kaseem [assumed spelling]
from Alif Laila Book Bus Society.
[ Applause ]
Next is Katrina Morse from the
Family Reading Partnership.
[ Applause ]
Next is Tara Libert from Free Minds
Book Club and Writing Workshop.
[ Applause ]
Next is Sapargul Mirseitova from
the Kazakhstan Reading Association.
[ Applause ]
Next is Charmead Schella from
Literacy Alberni Society.
[ Applause ]
>> Of the country so much.
>> Oh, I don't have --
next is Danielle Verbiest
from the Literacy Council
of Montgomery County, Maryland.
[ Applause ]
Todd Bol from the Little
Free Library.
[ Applause ]
Matt Sironas [assumed spelling] from
Men with a Message Braille Program.
[ Applause ]
Shanti Shovashanka from the
National Resource Center
for Non Formal Education.
[ Applause ]
Karen Hart from Picturebooks.
And Zev Lowe from Wordreader.
[ Applause ]
Also, I want to mention three
others who are not here right now.
One is Sister Mary M. Buckley
from Escuela Santo Nino Jesus
and she's expected later today.
And not here are representatives
from Stiftung Ellison [assumed
spelling] and Book Aid.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
We have some resource people
from the Library of Congress
who are joining us
for the presentations
and to be part of the discussion.
One of them is Karen
Keninger who is from the head
of our National Library for the
Blind and Physically Handicapped.
I'm not calling on her now, but
I just want to recognize her
and let's give her a round of
applause for being here today.
[ Applause ]
And a second is Leanne
Potter who is the Head
of the Educational Outreach
part of the Library of Congress
which is a close partner
of the Center for the Book,
the administrator of the award.
And part of the new educational
outreach effort of the Library
of Congress which coincides
very beautifully
with the literacy awards
program and one
of her specialties
is teacher outreach.
And Leanne is not able to
stay for the whole afternoon
so I've asked her to say a few words
before we start the presentations
and the program.
Leanne, I can't see you.
Where are you?
There you are.
Thank you.
Let's give her a hand.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Thanks so much.
I explained to John that
there were a couple of things
on my agenda this afternoon that
made me have to shorten my time.
One is we are hosting the
very first online conference
for teachers tonight
and tomorrow night.
And we've got programs
running from 4 O'clock
until 8 O'clock tonight
as well as tomorrow.
And my son broke his collar
bone on Saturday night.
So, my schedule at home
has shifted a little.
And the beauty of the online
conference is I can be involved
at home.
So, later I'm going to go
home, get my son, get him home,
get him comfortable, and then
I'm going to get to work.
We have a session tomorrow
night at 6 O'clock
on Literacy in Primary Sources.
So, if any of you are available
and want to participate
in an online conference, feel free
to join us tomorrow night at six.
If you go to the Library's website,
do a search on online
conference, you'll get the link.
It will also be recorded and I'll
be sure to share the link with John
so he can share that
with you as well.
Wanted to say a couple of other
things beyond the online conference.
As John said, my team
and I work very closely
with classroom teachers.
And our job is to alert them to the
online resources in the collections
of the Library of Congress.
We're all about teaching
with primary sources.
And more and more we're finding that
the teachers that we work with are
so committed to literacy efforts and
are finding some very clever ways
of integrating primary sources
and their literacy outreach,
whether it's identifying
primary sources that help
to illustrate novels that their
teachers are working with,
whether it's identifying
writing strategies that can come
from working with primary sources.
Some really creative things
are going on and we are trying
to reflect more and more of those
best practices within our blog.
I've got some bookmarks for you.
If you go on the Library's
website and you just go
to the loc.gov/teachers section,
that's where you can sign
up for the RSS feed of our blog.
Really encourage you to do that.
We love finding out what
you're doing and I have
to say I love this event and
I so regret not being able
to hang out this afternoon.
And I need to tell you that my folks
are coming to visit for Thanksgiving
and we're going to build
ourselves a little library.
So, the fact that the Little
Library folks are here,
my dad's actually pretty tickled.
He's one of those -- you know, he's
one of those retirees who got rid
of all of his tools
and saws and things.
And then he comes to my house
and wants to do projects.
This is the perfect Thanksgiving
project so thank you for that.
Congratulations to all of you.
If you ever have an interest
in working with educators
and more closely with the primary
source materials on the Library,
please reach out to me and my team.
We are really excited about
what you're doing and know
that there's some terrific
opportunities for great synergy.
Congratulations again.
Thanks for your time.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Leanne.
You can see that Leanne is --
her energy carries over to all of
our programs and we're very pleased
that she's working closely with
us, with the Center for the Book,
and with the Literacy programs.
Let me say a couple words about
what we're going to do next.
We thank you all for working
hard to develop on quick notice,
short presentations about
your best practices.
I know that some of you have
Power Points, some of you do not.
But what we are going to do
is to invite you to the podium
and John Regan [assumed spelling]
who is our audiovisual
specialist has your PowerPoint
if it has been given to him.
If not, we will proceed with
your particular best practice.
The note -- the idea was
that you would present
for at least five minutes about the
idea of yours and you would have
at least five minutes
to take questions
and answers from the audience.
If not, I may have a question.
And this will be a warmup for the --
the idea is that we will do as many
of these brief presentations
as we can.
We hope to do them all eventually.
We will take a break part way
through and then we'll come back
to our discussion tables where
we will have either members
of our board at those tables.
And I'll remind you
of the specialties
that some of our board members.
Karen will be at one of the tables.
Karen will be at the table actually
where we know we have
some best practices people
who would like to meet her.
A word about best practices
if I may before we start.
The literacy program from the
beginning knew that we needed
to honor more than just the
three winners because the purpose
of this literacy awards program
is to raise awareness in society
in general, nationally
and internationally,
about the importance of
literacy, promoting it,
and also finding new
organizations to be involved in it.
And Mr. Rubenstein's
idea was two-fold.
One was we do honor
those organizations
that are already involved in
the battle against illiteracy.
We do hope that it draws
new attention to literacy
and brings new groups in.
His feeling was that
literacy, while --
when Kathryn earlier read from
Dr. Borstein's statement --
that was the man who created
the Center for the Book,
the Librarian of Congress.
And that was back in -- it
would have been the early '80s
from the report on the future
of the book, we were worried
about the future of
books and reading then.
Then the technology that
Dr. Borstein addressed
and we were starting
to worry about --
this was before the
internet -- was television.
And when television came a
lot of people thought, "Uh-oh,
this is going to be
the end of the book."
And one of Dr. Borstein's
charges when we did the Book
in the Future was to will
at the problem and to look
at the current technologies
and to propose some solutions.
And his solution, which ran
through a little bit of the quote
that Kathryn read, was that
the problem isn't technology.
The problem that actually
technology can be combined and used
to promote books and reading.
And that's what is really
the symbol of the Center
for the Book's interest in part.
But that the real problem was
illiteracy and what our country did
about illiteracy in the long run
was what was really important.
And that is reflected actually
by Mr. Rubenstein two --
almost a decade and a half later who
felt that literacy was falling off
of the national agenda as a problem.
And that it didn't get as much
attention as it had in the past.
And that another reason
for our program in addition
to raising the awareness and
congratulating the winners is
to involve more groups, expand the
definition of literacy into society
so society realizes how
important literacy is.
And just a final example from
our literacy awards program,
we are reaching out and doing
symposia and how I've met a few
of you was -- one was through
the symposium we did on literacy
and poetry which brought
in poet groups interested
in promoting poetry and literacy.
We're doing one in the spring
on health and literacy.
Again, trying to expand
the definition
of literacy the point
out, in this case,
how health in many ways
is a literacy problem
and that world should be
involved in literacy as we are --
as either educators or librarians
or people who've had a record
of being involved in the field.
So, it's with that in mind that
I not only congratulate you,
but am eager to pick up
ideas that are in this book.
So, a further reference
will always be --
for your organization,
your page in this book.
But also this will
be the basis, I hope,
for some of the discussions this
afternoon where when you sit next
to somebody who is from another
organization, that you will be able
to see what they do and that by
the time the day is finished,
we'll know more about
each other's programs
and perhaps some new partnerships.
The program will end -- this
discussion will end at 4:30 when,
in fact, for our guests
we are providing tours
of this beautiful Jefferson
Building, which you're part of.
Which opened in 1897
when the Library
of Congress really
assumed its national role.
And the day doesn't
conclude with that.
We will have a reception
over in our other --
another building across the
street, the Madison Building.
You will be led there by your guide.
And another -- after the reception,
which is between 5:30 and 6:30,
Lisa Scol -- help me, somebody.
Scottoline.
Sorry. I was thinking of the food.
Lisa Scottoline who is a famous
mystery writer and a friend
of the Library of Congress,
a frequent visitor
to our National Book
Festival has a new book,
but she's also a literacy
advocate and she is going to talk
to us a little bit about literacy.
But a lot of her fans will be there
because this is publication day
for a new Lisa Scottoline mystery.
And there will be a
book signing following.
And so I hope you can
stay for that as well.
And we will be done at 7:30.
All of that said, I now want
to begin the presentations.
And we're going to follow the list
that Guy developed
which is alphabetical.
And the first person
I'm going to call
on is Basarat Kazim, Kazim perhaps.
Sorry about the pronunciation
ahead of time.
All right.
And it's at the Laila
Book Bus Society.
All right.
Thank you.
But you are from Pakistan.
>> Yes.
>> I have that part right.
So, please come on up.
And we'd like to learn
about your best practice.
Let's give her a little
encouragement.
[ Applause ]
>> Yes. Literacy and why literacy?
In a country like Pakistan where
the literacy rate is really low,
we felt very strongly that -- sorry.
I turned it off?
Yeah [laughing].
So, will you just run
the next slide then?
We did feel very strongly that books
and children need to come together.
And since 1978, that's what the
Alif Laila Book Bus has been doing.
Next please?
Before this, there were no libraries
-- children's libraries in Pakistan.
And this library that started off
in a double decker bus with books
as passengers was stationary.
And it drew children to it
like it was a magnet really.
Also, friends of children,
adults who had retained the child
within ran to this place.
And I think they gave it
their stamp of approval.
And that is how a very
poor project --
because it was I think even
poorer than a church mouse.
We had no money at all.
And it continued to run.
And I suppose that you know
when something is 37 years old,
there's stories and stories and
stories -- next slide please?
So, the library took on a life of
its own and it continued to grow.
Whereas because once people
were tickled by it and they felt
that you know, "What was this
old double decker bus all about?
Why was it drawing children?"
And at that time even the governor
of the Punjab sent some
[inaudible] there and said,
"You know we have really
big libraries.
There's a Punjab public library
and that's always sad and gloomy.
And I believe this children's
library attracts a lot of children.
So, what's happening there?"
And they found out
that it was just trust.
It was a belief in the children.
It was a belief in books.
It was a belief that a
connection between a child
and a book was a very vital thing.
And so the governor then gifted
to the society a building
which become the reference
library and that happened in '84.
Next please?
After that, we also felt
that because libraries were
committee centers essentially
and there were lots of activities
that could happen in libraries,
we started the hobby clubs project
which was actually skill based.
And the wonderful thing was
that we were drawing children
from the public sector where I'm
very sorry to say that teaching is
by rote and children
were having to memorize.
Sadly, they still do.
So, to our minds at Alif Laila,
this was not really learning.
This was being forced to
maybe pass exams perhaps.
And sometimes, I mean,
it's really so ridiculous
that children even need to memorize
the commas and the full stops
in the sentences, in the textbooks.
So, the hobby clubs were actually
project based learning centers
where the children could invent,
innovate through low cost
materials, build things.
And we were pretty
ambitious because in the '80s,
Alif Laila was the first
project to have computers
for children in Pakistan.
And then we did electronics
and we did mechanics
and we did craft and art.
So, through all these
projects they also learned
that book knowledge could actually
be translated into practice.
And if certain models or
things were going wrong,
they knew how to correct them.
So, they were thinking and
that's what we wanted them to do.
Next please?
Yes. And then the mobile
library came
in which was called
the Story Teller.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
-- In Urdu, which means,
again, the story teller.
This goes around to school.
Because they don't have libraries.
And this is a mobile program
which become very very successful.
And I'm really really
happy to tell you
that the government is
hoping to replicate it.
So, it's out in the newspapers.
It's on our Facebook page
as well that the government
of Punjab has said that they will
start a mobile library program.
They don't want to acknowledge us.
We don't mind as long
as they do that
and they let the libraries
run all over.
Next.
Next slide, please?
Yes. We had a rather bad
earthquake two days back I Pakistan.
But fortunately the epicenter
was not heavily populated
so there was not a lot of loss.
But in 2005, in [foreign
language spoken].
Sorry. The earthquake was terrible.
And at that point in time Alif
Laila's also the Pakistan chapter
for IBBY, which is the International
Board on Books for Young People.
And IBBY gave us the
funds to set up a library
for these children in Bagh.
And that's the library you see here.
It was called [foreign
language speak], rainbow.
And, again, I mean there's
just so many beautiful stories
because so many children who
were completely traumatized
because the earthquake happened
when they were in school.
And I remember myself
going and working with them
through puppets and play.
And one child was very scared to
come anywhere near a crowd kept sort
of standing outside and then all of
a sudden, when she saw the puppets,
she ran in and she stayed.
And then when she ran out
and she told her mother,
"I passed the exam."
So, that was her exam of being
able to overcome her fear.
Next please?
Yes. These are, again, the different
libraries, the different looks.
Because we do set up libraries
all over Pakistan now.
Next please?
This was a project that we did which
was called Scheherazade Ka Khazana.
The Alif Laila gets its name
from the Thousand and One Nights.
And, of course, Scheherazade
told those thousand
and one stories to
keep herself alive.
And actually, you know, changed
the way that the king thought
because he was not a good king
at all before he got involved
in her stories and then married her.
So, Alif Laila, the project
itself has been struggling
like Scheherazade and keeping itself
through telling of different tales.
And so we named one project
Scheherazade Ka Khazana,
which means Scheherazade's
treasure trove.
And actually did a thousand
and one books and sent them,
again, all over Pakistan.
This we did with Save the Children.
And they were the funding
organization.
Yes, next please.
So, the -- this is a library that
we did in Sheikhupura which is
on the outskirts of Lahore.
And, yes, now we have small mobile
libraries going into those areas
where the big story
teller bus cannot go.
And the children of the community
come out and they take their books
and they read and then it visits
them every week or every two weeks.
Yes, next please.
These are libraries that
we started in Madrassah.
Madrassahs are religious schools.
And the children from
the Madrassahs, again,
just learn the Qur'an by rote.
And we felt that it was necessary
for them to know a little more
and to be excited about the world
and books and other children
to get a better understanding
of the Qur'an.
So, these are libraries
that we've set up there.
Next please.
These are Rickshaw libraries.
These little three-legged
rickshaws that go into, you know,
very -- are my five minutes up?
>> Yes, they are.
>> OK. I'm done [laughing].
Yes. So, any questions?
>> We have time for one question
but I think we're going to have
to limit this to no more
than 10 minutes total.
And you've managed to
give us more information,
but part of it was
in your Q and A time.
So, if you don't mind.
>> No. I don't mind.
I don't mind.
>> So, if there's time -- if
there's one question, we'll take it?
If not, let's thank her and we
will continue the discussion,
as I said, later after the break.
But thank you very much.
That was [inaudible].
>> And I'm really sorry
I took more time.
I never ever do, but I think
this crowd was so phenomenal
that I just wanted to keep talking.
Thank you.
>> Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Next is Katrina Morse from the
Family Reading Partnership.
Katrina?
>> We're two, we're a team.
We're a team.
>> We're a team.
>> OK. Hi, I'm Katrina and this is
Eliza Stilwell who's my Co-Director
and we're honored to
have our founder
in the audience, Bridget Hoverman.
So, we're happy she can be here
to share the award with us.
>> Yes. So, Family
Reading Partnership.
We do more than give
books, we change lives.
And to just try to
quickly tell the story
of this amazing organization
in five minutes.
It started with -- sure.
Here?
>> Yes.
>> OK. It started with,
again, our founder hearing
from kindergarten teachers
in our community
that children were
still entering school
with little or no book experience.
And she convened community
members and said,
"What can we do about this?
What can we do to insure
that all children
in our community have
early, frequent,
and pleasurable experiences
with books at home?"
So, that is how the
story began 18 years ago.
And our goal is, our mission
is to create a culture
of literacy one book, one
child, one family at a time.
And this is what this looks like.
We really are focusing on supporting
family reading practices at home,
ensuring book ownership for
children, and really working
within existing partnerships
within our community.
That's how the magic happens.
And the way that works, we do
have 12 different programs.
Whoops. I get to say
one second about that.
We did bring materials with
brochures that go in more depth
about the programs, but we
start before the beginning.
So, in our community every
expectant family receives a book
from their obstetrician or
midwife encouraging them
to start reading even
before the baby's born.
At birth, they are gifted with
The Very Hungry Caterpillar,
which Eric Carle calls
a story of hope.
And it's in a bag that
says, "Love me,
feed me, take me to the library."
we have a program really
modeled after Reach Out and Read
but we call it Books to Grow On.
And whoops, again, in our
community, every child beginning
at their two month well
child checkup receives a book
from their pediatrician with
the prescription, "read to me,"
signed by the pediatrician.
Again, we recognize that
when books are given
through trusted partnerships the
value of that book is increased.
And also that all children
in our community are
receiving the same books.
So, we are building community
through gifting these books.
Also, each of these books is
sponsored by a local business
or foundation so that it's a way to
include everybody in this process.
OK. We like to mark
special occasions.
So, children are welcomed to
kindergarten, again, county-wide --
whoops -- with a Welcome
to School book.
And this is what it looks like.
So, kinds in our community --
all kids in our community
receive all these books.
This is the collection
that they have
by the time they are four years old.
OK. We also realize that it's
important to have book access
and our goal of creating a culture
of literacy means that books --
there has to be an
abundance of books everywhere.
So, we have 50 Bright
Red Bookshelves,
which circulate gently used
children's books throughout
the community.
And what's special about this
is each bookshelf has a tender.
It might be a family.
It might be an organization.
But throughout the
year we do book drives.
April is Faith in Books Month
for Family Reading Partnership
so all the religious
congregations collect books.
They come back to our organization.
Volunteers clean them, sort
them, put them on bookshelves.
Then our Bright Red Bookshelves
tenders can come collect them,
and bring them out
there to their shelf.
OK. We have an annual
event in two weeks.
You're all invited
in Ithaca, New York.
I forgot to say we were from Ithaca.
Kids' Book Fest, a
celebration focusing on books.
Every school aged child
-- actually pre-K
through 3rd grade receives the
featured book, which this year is --
out theme is The World of Eric
Carle, The Mixed-Up Chameleon.
And the entire community
celebrates this --
celebrates books and reading.
OK. We recognize that in
creating this culture we also need
to have more resources for
families with greater need.
So, during the holiday season,
we have Give the Gift of Reading.
Families at WIC sites can choose
a brand new book, wrap it,
and have it as part of their
children's holiday celebration.
We have a new Welcome to WIC book.
So, Rah Rah Radishes.
If you haven't read it, you need to.
It's fabulous.
It's the joy of vegetables
in a ruckus chant.
And, again, this weaving of books
throughout family's life throughout
the community.
We have a wonderful program
called Read Along Songs,
which goes out to Headstart
and Pre-K kids.
And, again, it's a tool
for family engagement
in that it uses music along with
children can hear the books,
they can read the pictures or
they can hear the books sung.
And I'm going to have Katrina just
speak briefly about these next --
these next materials which are
tools for family engagement.
Yeah. We developed three special
First one is a Read to Me Calendar.
This is -- hopefully some of
you have it because we have it
in our packets that you're
welcome to take back with you.
This is -- oh.
Just.
>> It goes by itself.
>> Oh, it does?
Oh, OK. OK.
Well, anyway the calendar
is filled with illustrations
from nationally known children's
book illustrators and all
of them are about reading together.
So, the calendar goes to
Pre-K and Headstart families.
In December, they get to take it
home and wrap it for their families
and bring it back as a gift.
They also have it in the classroom
so they can make a
school to home connection.
Then -- did we miss one?
OK. So At Home with Books.
I had the pleasure of
writing and illustrating.
It's a story about the bear family
and all the fun they
have reading at home.
But woven into the story is our
tips for parents on how to read.
So, it gives ways and methods of how
you can have fun with reading aloud.
And we also developed materials so
that Headstart and Pre-K classrooms
and home based programs
can use this as a way
to develop a culture
of literacy in homes.
And Love Those Letters is
-- it does go by itself.
OK. Love Those Letters is a book.
It's a brand new alphabet book
that was borne out of a need
in our community to have a
consistent key words throughout the
community so that when children went
to school they all learned the
alphabet through different keywords,
the same keywords from
school to school.
And there is -- this was a
big collaborative effort.
We have someone who
made a dance and a song.
I did the illustrations
for the book.
We also have school materials
that are used in classrooms.
So, that's given to
Pre-K and kindergarten
and Headstart families
in classrooms.
>> And, again, the idea is
about having children not just learn
the alphabet but love the alphabet,
really connecting families
and children
around the joy of learning letters.
OK. So, we should have
been done, but we weren't.
We recognized all of these
things were happening and
yet we needed to start earlier.
So, our newest initiative is called
Every Baby Every Day Talk Sing
Read Play.
And we created a community call to
action with an envisioning, again,
what would it take in our
community to have every baby grow
up surrounded by words, songs,
and stories right from the start.
What would we need to do?
So, we created a community-wide
invitation, giant,
nine by 12 foot banners on buildings
throughout our community saying,
"Spread the word.
Be a part of it."
We -- there is going up
at our grocery store.
Lawn signs, we have 500 lawn signs.
We put them in flocks
and said, "Take one!
Share the message.
Bring it home."
And people did.
And our mayor has a lawn sign
and we had all our community leaders
record public service announcements
and say, "Come on.
We can do this."
Very compelling messages.
And we train -- we recognize
that babies and toddlers,
there's often empty waiting
for them in places like WIC
and social service agencies
and even in child care.
So, we trained baby reading
buddies to be people that went out
and did talk, sing, read,
play, modeling and supporting.
Families through our
home visiting program
through the health department
receive a special bag of books
from their nurses at their
seven month visit prenatally.
And there they are happy to bring
our message out with their message.
And our last part of this
is we convened all six
of our county libraries for this
initiative called Babies Belong
at the Library and issue a Baby's
First Library Card with that book
at birth, our Welcome Baby book.
These libraries also agreed
that there would be no fine
on board books to really
encourage all families
and our message was, "Come.
Stay. Play.
Let the libraries be
one of the first places
that families bring babies
and never stop going."
So, that is our reading magic.
OK. A little more than five minutes.
No time for questions.
Sorry. We will answer
your questions later.
OK.
>> I feel like the ice man commeth.
You know, I'm creeping up behind,
but I think we need a new bargain
and that is every group gets
10 minutes max and I'm going
to start edging up
about seven minutes.
And if you'd like to
take the 10 minutes,
there will just be no questions.
But if you want -- can
do it in five minutes,
we'll have a chance
to have questions.
But, as I said, the real other
way to look at it is we're warming
up for the discussion and if
you have further questions
about the group, look at --
sit at the tables together
and you can do kind of a round
robin, "I'd like to know more
about something," and we'll make
that a different kind of discussion
so we have a chance
for everyone to get in.
Now, I must say though,
Katrina mentioned Bridget
Hoverman who is the founder.
And Bridget is with us and I'd like
her just to stand up and take a bow.
Bridget, thank you for founding
Family Reading Partnership.
[ Applause ]
Our next speaker is Tara
Libert, Free Minds Book Club
and Writing Workshop from
District of Columbia.
Tara? There you are.
[ Applause ]
It's so exiting.
I've got so many good ideas.
I want to do the rickshaw
libraries with the guys and ride
around in DC just -- I'm so
excited to learn all this stuff.
So, we are local, not from far
away Pakistan and less than a mile
from here at the DC jail something
magical happens every Tuesday.
Young boys who are 16, 17 years old,
most have dropped out of school.
Most have never read a book
cover to cover, written a poem,
and they're all charged with
felony crimes, armed robbery,
series crimes, begin -- open a book
and begin a journey
of transformation.
It's pretty amazing.
We have a video so I'll let the
video take you inside the jail,
which is hard to get into.
But we -- a couple of big --
couple of points I wanted to share.
In a prison, very little
is your own choice,
so a big part of our book club,
it's just like any regular
book club is a book ballot.
So, this is what they
get to choose the book
that we're going to
talk about that week.
And these are some popular books
and we can share these with you.
And they learn to agree to disagree.
And it's young men who have
lifelong enemies on the street,
with violence in their neighborhood,
learn that, "I can agree.
I can say I don't like that
book or that character,
but I respect your opinion."
And it's a pretty amazing thing
to watch how they become readers
and they join a new club
instead of the street gang.
They become a book club member.
So, take it away Don.
We'll show the video.
[ Music and Sirens ]
>> To my teenager is under arrest.
>> First of all, the teens
gave a statement to police
without their parents present.
>> He's now being held without bond.
>> Three of four teenagers
have now died.
>> We have 9News crews
going to the scene.
>> It was the only life they knew.
>> Back then I didn't
really care about anyone.
>> I just [inaudible] the streets.
That was my job.
>> Jose and William were teenagers
charged with crimes in Washington,
D.C. As juveniles treated as adults,
they ended up here at the DC jail.
[ Music ]
>> I just decided to do -- hang
around with the wrong crowd
and it finally caught up to me.
>> Behind bars with
nowhere to run, isolation
and loneliness caught
up with them too.
>> I didn't have any type
of hope of ever going home.
>> Little did they know, a
second chance would come along,
a chance for them to
make things right again.
>> My name is Tara Libert, I am
the Co-Founder and Deputy Director
of the Free Minds Book
Club and Writing Workshop.
>> I'm Kelly Taylor and I'm
Executive Director of Free Minds.
>> I was incarcerated sitting
in a jail cell contemplating
on what I want to do with
myself, what I was going to be.
And all of a sudden Free Minds came
into my life and helped me out.
>> What'd you guys think?
Off the top, thumbs up, thumbs down?
>> First of all --
>> Free Minds, a book club
that introduces reading
and creative writing
to young inmates.
>> We're reaching these kids
at a really critical
point in their lives.
These kids are coming home
and it might be two years,
it might be four years, but
they are coming home and we need
to consider how do we
want them coming back.
>> At first, it wasn't easy to
convince William and Jose to join.
>> I was like Free Minds Book Club?
I don't want to read no books.
>> I hated reading.
>> But Free Minds never gave up.
>> I was following blindly.
I realized --
>> Eventually for William and Jose,
the books led them to a new world,
a world of possibilities, a
place they'd never dreamt of.
[ Music ]
And sometimes to a world
that was very familiar.
>> One of them that I relate a
lot to is called My Bloody Life.
It was about this young guy that,
he just got himself caught
up in a lot of things.
He involved himself with gangs and
then, you know, he got incarcerated
and then he finally say,
you know, the light.
He decided to change.
It was very inspiring.
>> Soon, they also discovered the
power of writing their own poetry.
>> When you read a
book, it's like --
and write poetry, it's like it
opens up a brand new side of you,
a side you never knew
that you had in you.
[ Music ]
>> It made me stop to think
that I really do care,
that I really do want to change.
If I didn't put that
on paper I didn't --
I don't think I would
have realized it.
[ Music ]
>> When it was time to go home,
time to enter the outside world
once again, Free Minds was there.
>> I never thought
that I had people --
it was people out here that would
care for me like Free Minds.
Kelly, Tara, they kept in touch
with me every month, regular basis.
>> They helped these
young men find training.
And build a path to their future.
>> I don't know.
I've never built anything before
and once, you know, you actually got
into doing the boats and building
them and actually starting them
from scratch, when you
actually finish them,
you know, I got a sense of pride.
You know, like, "Yeah.
I built that boat."
>> Congratulations.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
[ Music ]
>> Kelly and I knew
they could do it,
but they didn't know
they could do it
and now they know they could do it.
I'm so excited!
>> Now that world of
possibility they'd only read
about is suddenly becoming
a reality.
William and Jose now
have jobs working
with a local construction company.
They opened up their lives all
because these two opened a book.
>> Basically they changed
my life around.
>> It gave me hope.
It kind of gave me a place, you know
to still have dreams and faith that,
you know, things were
going to be OK.
>> Now, others are
following in their steps.
>> It hurts to see myself in jail.
>> Reading and writing
their own ticket to freedom.
[ Music ]
>> I go to sleep each and
every night and I meet myself
in the morning [inaudible].
>> Right now most of all it's
[inaudible] taught me right
from wrong.
>> Dear Momma, you
[inaudible] from a boy to a man.
How I stood up for myself
and I never ever ran.
[ Music ]
>> I don't know how we are on
time, but just to report William
and Jose are doing wonderfully.
That video -- I look a
little younger in that video.
Couple years old.
They're master carpenter and
Jose is a mechanic for RV's,
the only one on the East Coast
if you have an RV trip --
one of those huge buses.
He's pretty amazing.
Another thing we do is
we collect their poetry
and we publish literary journals.
This is our newest one, The
Untold Story of the Real Me.
And we have write nights where
we have the poems printed out
and community members and
provide feedback on the poems
and then we mail it --
bring it in to the young men
and it creates a connection to the
community and changes perceptions.
So, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
We're making executive
decisions as we go.
I think what we'll do is
change the schedule a little
and have three more and then take a
five minute break and then come back
and do the other four, five, or
six depending on how many we have.
And then take another
five minute break
because actually these are
wonderful, but they're intense.
And they change subjects rapidly and
I think we all need a little time
to absorb what we're seeing and
think about it a little bit in view
of the discussion that's coming up.
So, we will now have, I
believe, speaker number four.
And that's Sapargul Mirseitova
from The Kazakhstan
Reading Association --
Reading Association, yes.
Thank you very much.
Sapargul. Give her a hand.
[ Applause ]
>> Actually we started
earlier in 1997.
It was in the international
program, Reading and Writing
for Critical Thinking,
which brought us together.
And on the initiative of
the first participants,
we established Kazakhstan
Reading Association in 2002.
The aim was to engulf
our teachers more
in leadership and problem solving.
So, here you see that we have legal
entities in each regional center.
So, for teachers all
over the country to be --
to be easier to get support from
our trainers in these centers.
The next one.
So, what is KazRA in numbers today?
More than 40,000 teachers are
certified by the Reading and Writing
for Critical Thinking program.
Each year we have about 3,000
members not considering that many
of our teachers defended
doctoral dissertations,
they got career promotions,
and higher teaching categories.
And what is the focus of KazRA?
Each year we have national
and regional conferences.
And this year we had the 15th
national conference on reading.
Teacher research different vision
on July 2015 in Western Part
of Kazakhstan [inaudible].
So, we moved from one part
of the country to another
to have our national conference
to involve more teachers
to give them chance to participate
if they cannot travel
longer distances.
Next one. We also publish --
and this is our issue of quarterly
journal, Voice and Vision.
It is a professional
journal of teachers.
And very popular among
teachers in the country.
So, and also we publish
books and 16 titles
of books were published so far.
And they are in two languages
in Kazakh and Russian.
So, and each year at the national
conference one evening is devoted
to the auction.
Money collected from the
auction, we use for KazRA awards.
Teachers bring souvenirs and
drawings from their students.
So, we try to use all of
these at these auctions.
So, we have the best KazRA reader
of the year, the best KazRA writer
of the year, and the best
KazRA illustrator of the year.
So, this is our Executive Director
and she is together with the winner
as the best writer in 2015.
And this is the best
reader with her teacher.
And she's also the KazRA trainer.
Thanks. These are students, the
best writer and the best illustrator
with their teacher
also a KazRA trainer.
So, I would like to
read what they wrote
for our quarterly journal,
Voice and Vision.
Some of these winners.
"I became a winner of many contests
this year, but I have enjoyed none
of them except this one because here
I was doing not what I had been told
to do, but what I wanted myself
and felt how it should be."
Camilla Kulmaganbetova, grade eight.
Thanks. The best writer.
"First, I've got confused
because there are
so many talented students around.
Then I realized it might be that
my work worthies to be valued.
I became proud of myself.
Though, what is pride?
Today you may have it, tomorrow not.
Therefore, need to
continue writing."
I want to add that this student,
Yana, she wrote a piece --
a wonderful piece of continuation
of To Kill a Mockingbird.
First, I just was reading
and saying, "So, what is it?
The same style.
The same wording, you know?
And then just different events."
And so she imagined that it is 10
years past and this little girl,
she came from another city,
New York, is a student.
University student.
And she -- and her vision now after
growing up about your childhood
in some kind of reflection
on all this.
So, she is very talented.
Thank you.
That's it.
[ Applause ]
>> So, I was quicker [laughing].
>> Well, is there a question?
We actually have a couple minutes.
All right.
Well, thank you very much.
And we'll continue the discussion.
Our next speaker is Charmead Schella
from the Literacy Alberni
Society of Canada.
[ Applause ]
>> You're not the first.
That's all right.
Thank you.
Fabulous. Oh, that's the end.
But that's OK [laughing] because you
know what I don't think I'm going
to use it anyway.
I would like to try
to exercise brevity.
Literacy Alberni Society is located
in Port Alberni on Vancouver Island.
We've actually been in
the news since Sunday
because there was a tragic whale
watching tour boat that capsized
and five tourists were killed.
Anyway, that's not why I'm
here but it's been shocking
because I've been here since.
But I would like to offer a
very brief thumbnail sketch
of Port Alberni.
Port Alberni is tiny with a
population of 18,000 people.
Our illiteracy rate
is a shocking 42%.
People tend to be a little
bit shocked when I say this
as a Canadian because we are a
developed country in the first world
and yet our illiteracy
rate is so high.
So, as such, we do have a bit
of a slog in Port Alberni trying
to address the issues that sort
of create this illiteracy rate.
As such, we have a
myriad of programs.
I am the Executive Director
at Literacy Alberni Society
and we don't offer sort
of one best practice.
We have a myriad of things
that we try to use to help.
So, the first one that
we use is called CALP,
and it's our Community
Adult Literacy Program
under which fall any programming
that basically addresses people
who are 18 years and older.
We employ methods that
address computer literacy,
nutritional literacy, which is
like cooking classes and that kind
of thing, family literacy,
which is the big one.
Basically monitoring for
parents who perhaps had children
at a very young age,
which happens quite a bit
in my community and such.
So, the second program
that's very popular
at Literacy Alberni is our ESL and
settlement assistance programming
because we also offer a great deal
of literacy support to immigrants
who are new to the community.
So, we offer programming at not just
in terms of language acquisition
but also in terms of orientation
and becoming familiar
with the community.
As you can imagine, as a very
isolated forestry based community
on the very isolated West
Coast of Vancouver Island,
it can be a big jarring to come
from metropolitan China or Iran
or Pakistan or India or
a myriad of other places.
So, this program's very
popular at our center as well.
And I was delighted to meet Tom at
my table who's from Little Libraries
because we have just introduced
the Little Library program
to Port Alberni.
Brand new actually in September.
We've just introduced 26 Little
Libraries into the community.
A very very big step for the
community, which seems minor,
but it's actually quite large.
I was marveling at the first
presentation because I can relate
so closely to the idea
of just providing books
and the accessibility to
books whether that be free,
whether that be lending,
whatever that case is.
So, a really quick
story before I finish.
I really don't want
to speak too long.
Our Little Libraries,
we built 26 of them.
And put them out into the community.
And two of the Little Libraries went
as far west as we can on the island,
specifically to Ucluelet and Tofino.
And we sort of thought
that's where they would stop.
Two of our First Nations
communities out there thought
that they would have a better home.
So, they popped them
on a fishing boat
and took them very far northwest
to two First Nations inaudible
communities called Uchucklesaht
and Opitsaht.
And Opitsaht is a community
of about 200 people.
And our Little Library is the first
library they've actually ever had.
I know! So, it's a
really lovely story.
Anyway, we do have
other programming,
but I am going to stop there.
And I will take any
questions if there any.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Our next speaker is Danielle
Verbiest from the Literacy Council
of Montgomery County, Maryland.
Danielle. Let's give
her some encouragement.
[ Applause ]
>> All right.
Good afternoon, everyone.
So, my name is Danielle Verbiest.
I'm the Executive Director
of the Literacy Council here
in Montgomery County, Maryland.
So, we are local.
We're a part of the greater DC area.
Let's move -- let's see
if I can navigate this.
Yes! I want to start real
brief by giving you an overview
of the organization as a whole
before I start giving you some more
information about the program
that we're recognized for.
So, the Literacy Council Montgomery
County, short MCMC, was established
in 1963 initially as a
one-on-one tutoring program.
So, the -- the founder was Beth
Kilgore and she saw a great need
in our community for
basic literacy services.
The county grew, a lot of
immigrants moved into the community,
and we added ESL tutoring
services to that.
So, right now, just to give
you a sense, we are serving
about 1,600 adults every year.
Since inception, we have
served 18,500 adults.
Most of our students
are ESL students.
So, they're mostly immigrants.
Last year we had people from
85 plus countries represented
in our student base
including the United States.
Most of our students
are female, 75%.
And we do all of this together
with a vast volunteer base.
We have trained and supported over
9,000 volunteers since our inception
and currently we have about
650 active volunteers.
Let's see.
So, to give you an overview.
So, as I mentioned, we have our
one-on-one tutoring program.
The one-on-one tutoring program
is entirely volunteer based
and we use a curriculum that's
called the [inaudible] method.
We also have intensive
standards based ESL classes.
Last year we did 49
classes county-wide.
We also have an English
for daily living program,
family literacy program where
we partner with local schools
and we have a GED online
preparation program.
We have conversation classes where
we offer students the opportunity
to practice speaking English
as they wait for a tutor
or as they try to advance
their skills.
We also have workplace
literacy classes.
We have two models.
The main model is where we
actually work with employers.
We are currently working with the
Maryland National Capital Parks
and Planning Commission
to offer a couple
of classes to their employees.
And we piloted a new program last
year that is sort of a hybrid
between tutoring and classroom where
we actually go out to, in this case,
a restaurant where we meet
the students between lunch
and dinner shift and
provide tutoring services.
And then the one that
we are recognized
for here today is our
Health Literacy program.
So, we started last year.
Let's see.
So, we started last
year with a pilot.
We got funding from the
National Libraries of Medicine.
We started the English
for Health program.
The English for Health
program teaches adults
to navigate the health care system
and maintaining good health not only
for themselves but of course
also for their families.
The curriculum was actually
developed in Wisconsin.
They were recognized for that
in 2010 as a best practice.
We purchased the curriculum.
We made some adaptations to
that for our student base,
and it's been going very well.
We are partnering with
local community's clinics
as well as a hospital.
So, it's really a partnership.
They help us with outreach.
They provide also some
presenters from the field.
We do that, you know,
very well in this program.
We get presenters to focus
on the actual practical
part of going to the doctor.
We have mock clinics which is one
of the favorite components
of this program.
So, here you see some pictures.
So, with this English
for Health program,
we directly address low health
literacy rates among adults here
in our community.
And we also see that by bringing in
the professionals from the field,
it's a win-win situation
because they also get
to experience what it really
means to communicate effectively
with adults with low literacy rates.
So, we, you know, of course, we
are here today and we look forward
to connecting with
more of you here today.
So, I'm joined by our Director
of Programs, Christine Neil.
So, if you have any questions,
you know, just please come over
and we'll look forward
to talking to you.
[ Applause ]
>> I would just like to point out
that thus far, this first third
of our -- or first half
of our presentations
that we have really hit on
organizations and they've come
at you alphabetically as best we
can figure out our score card here.
And we've hit four of the
five categories by chance,
but it in fact they should all be
here by the time we're through.
But here are the five
categories the way
in which you are organized
according to our best practices.
Literacy in the service of social
goals, creating a community
of literacy, literacy working with
government policy makers -- oops!
I missed one.
But we'll have to all
look at our books.
Another one coming up is
providing access to readers
with physical disabilities.
And by the time we're through,
we'll have examples from each
of these categories
of best practices.
We had a discussion this
morning with our advisory group
about the evolving idea of best
practices and how last year
when we gave these awards,
we had different categories.
They're all related to literacy and
literacy promotion, but they depend
in part on the applications
we get each year.
This is our third year.
The first year we were
overwhelmed with applications.
We had over 189.
But it turned out that
because it was our first year
and various problems
in working that out,
a number of them didn't
prove to be eligible.
Most of them were, but there
was a number that were not.
The next two years, we've had more
along the lines of 90 applications.
This is both from the
US and from abroad.
But by and large as -- they
have been better applications
and fewer have been
disqualified, very few.
And we have still been able to
widen the range of categories
and change the categories,
which is what we want
to do in continuing this.
And I'd like to point out that with
this experience under your belt,
I hope that you will encourage other
groups to apply for the awards.
We also are making an effort
to reach deeper into states
on the US side and the same
is true really for countries.
We've had a variety
of countries involved.
We're working hard through UNESCO
and other national organizations
to advertise the program.
But one thing we'd like you to help
us do is to encourage more groups
to apply and that is a way
that we think we can strengthen
the overall picture of literacy
and literacy promotion
both in our country
and especially around the world.
We have been surprised, I must --
I'll conclusion my little part --
this time by the extent
of international interest
in the program.
And it's made us realize that we
need to continue to encourage it
and to continue to develop some
of these best practices categories
that will help encourage other
countries and other programs
to apply for programs
-- apply for awards.
Well, it gives me a
great deal of pleasure
to introduce our next speaker.
Many of you have met
in other circumstances,
but it's Mr. Little Free Library
himself, Todd Bol from Wisconsin.
Todd, Little Free Library.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I'm very very honored to be here.
I have to tell you a story.
I was at a literacy
conference in Wisconsin.
We received a Literacy of the Year
Award and former Governor Doyle,
from Wisconsin, came up to me.
And he said, "You know, what's going
on in America right now is not us.
We're not this polarized.
We're not this separated."
He said, "Little Free Library
is more about what we're about."
He said, "We reach across the
aisle, we reach across the street,
we help each other,
we lift each other up.
That's who we are as Americans."
And when I thought about that
earlier today I realized that's
who we all are.
What's unique about literacy
and the literacy movement
is we have a great we.
And we have a great sense of
helping everybody on a global basis,
on a common goal and
a common ground.
And what's unique about us is we
have a we without really an other.
There's no villain.
There's nobody on the other side.
There's nobody that we're against.
What we're really about
is bringing together
and it's a better side
of our humanity.
It's a better side of who we are.
And I think that's what's great
about us and I think that's great
about everybody in this room that
I'm so honored to be a part of.
Little Free Library, as you
instead, it says, "We all do better
when we all read better."
We borrowed that from Paul
Wellstone, the senator of Minnesota.
He said we all do better
when we all do better.
And we know that reading
is a part of it.
By the end of the year, we'll
have 40,000 Little Free Libraries.
We'll be in over 90
countries, 50 states,
200,000 books a day get exchanged
over 60,000,000 --
60,000,000 books a year.
Yeah. I like that.
It's a good start.
That's my mom.
Like many of you who've
lost your parents,
I couldn't believe she died.
I couldn't believe it.
A great spirit was left.
And when she died, at her funeral, I
gave out a little nickels that said,
"June A. Bol, a Dancing
Spirit, 1927 through."
And I never put an end date to it.
And I consider my mom's dance
to be all around the world.
The spirit of my mom lives through
each and every Little Free Library
and every time I see one I
seem like I have another child.
It's great.
We're all across the globe,
South Korea, Israel, Japan.
And we have a book, a
wonderful book was written
about Little Free Library.
LA Times said it was almost
perfect literary democracy.
San Francisco Gate said, "It's
one of America's better exports."
I like that.
Minneapolis Paper called it
pint sized social justice.
I like that.
And last week Amazon.com,
of all things --
and those of you that are in
my age category will appreciate
that fine complement --
it said it's the best book
since the 1970s Whole Earth Catalog.
It has great signs of hope
and a great future for us all
because it's leading really
the giving and sharing economy.
And how great to have that giving
and sharing economy be about books.
We've gotten great reviews.
Pick up the book.
You can find it at
LittleFreeLibrary.com,
at your local bookstore,
and other places.
Governor Doyle, again.
It's -- many nice things
have been said about us.
We've been told that we are a global
sensation, a cultural phenomenon,
but what I really love is we've
been called the newest micro
lending system.
We've also been called a revolution
and neighborhood conversation
and a folk art revival.
I like that.
And, of course, my
kids groan at this one
and I tell this any chance I get.
We were in 50 Surprising Reasons
We Love America, Bon Jovi,
Bruce Springsteen, number
50, Michelle Obama, 35.
Sorry, Michelle.
Bill Gates, number 25.
And at the heel of sliced bread
-- we're not quite sliced bread --
is Little Free Libraries.
All right.
Just after Thanksgiving,
we passed McDonalds.
We're have more libraries
than McDonalds, more locations
than McDonalds, and of
course you know we have
to say more books than burgers.
Probably get us sued, but
I think that's brilliant.
I can't wait.
And our goal is by 2017 to have
over 100,000 Little Free
Libraries throughout the world.
Our ultimate goal is to have them
all around the world and serve
as a lightning rod to stimulate
local and grass roots literacy.
And what we've developed out
of this is something called
Literacy-Friendly Neighborhood.
And this is our key Marque program.
And what Literacy-Friendly
Neighborhood is designed to do is
to say to neighbors, "You can't take
care of your state or your country,
each city, but maybe you can
take care of your neighborhood."
And what we've done is taken the
ideas of thousands and thousands
of Little Free Library stewards
around the globe and put them
in something called a literacy
friendly neighborhood toolkit.
It's something that we can all
partner with, we can all use.
It's a form of civil rights.
It's we all have a right to read.
And the neighborhoods
are the key area
that we have to help each other.
We are doing something across
the country called Kids,
Community, and Cops.
We're building 100 Little
Free Libraries in a day.
We're bringing in children.
We're bringing in Black
Lives Matter.
We're bringing in policemen and
we're putting these together.
And in some communities they're
asking via Facebook page,
"What is your favorite
book about understand?
How do you build understand
in your community?"
And we're starting to get support
from such groups as the FBI
and the Treasury Department and
police and corporations and so on.
We plan on doing one in Washington,
by the way, at the end of June.
And we have one planned in
Los Angeles February 20th
and Minneapolis February 21st.
We have up to 600 people come in and
put these Little Free Libraries up
and give them throughout
the communities.
We put in 11 Little Free Libraries
in Madison area about
three years ago.
Now we have over 500.
I put up three Little Free
Libraries in the Twin Cities area
of Minneapolis and Saint Paul.
Now we have over 4,000
throughout Minnesota
and it's growing faster and faster.
And there's my Little
Free Library vehicle.
If any of you remember Felix
the Cat, this is our little bag
of tricks, this wagon -- I
mean this trailer and we travel
across the country and
soon to be a city near you.
Little Free Library, you can
help in all kinds of ways.
I was just down in Mississippi and
I spoke at the library conference.
And they decided that they are
going to put a Little Free Library
in every small town in Mississippi.
There are over 11,000
towns across America
without books, no library
whatsoever.
So, in Mississippi, they're going
to make sure that they have one.
I have several groups
from Canada that would
like to celebrate their 175th --
including that young
later over there --
celebrate their 175th
birthday in 2015
by putting a Little Free Library
in every small town across Canada.
And so we're trying to do that and I
encourage each and every group here
to use Little Free Library,
borrow our materials, take --
go look at Literacy-Friendly
Neighborhood,
which can be downloaded.
Take our pictures.
Take our models.
Do whatever you want.
And use Little Free Library to
help improve your community.
And also come back to help us.
We're interested in materials
and anything you can provide us
because we want to make them
available for everybody.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Do I have time for one question?
No? I used all my time, John?
>> We're in the same
position we've often been in.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm telling you that time is up.
>> But I [inaudible].
It was 33 seconds.
>> You did -- well you
want to give a conclusion?
>> Oh.
>> In a sentence or two?
We've done this before.
>> A gentleman came
up to me and said
that Little Free Libraries
are like air conditioning.
You know? And I said, "What?"
He said, "Yeah, air conditioning.
What happened to us is in the
'60s we all got off the porch,
stopped reading, went in the house,
turned on the air conditioning,
shut the door, shut the
windows, turned on the TV
and the digital divide began.
And now with Little Free
Library we're talking again."
And I think we should all use
that to make things better.
>> Great. Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> At the National Book
Festival this year,
Center for the Book plays
a key role in the Library
of Congress National Book Festival.
We had a literacy corner
for the first time.
And Little Free Library
plus a couple
of our other partners were there.
And a very popular part of it.
And we are going to continue
to have a literacy corner
at the National Book Festival.
And I hope that, as the years
role by, that we'll be able
to include more partners and
more of this idea of new ways
of promoting literacy, innovative
ways that catch the eye and are --
go to places where
there aren't books.
And I didn't know the Mississippi
story that Todd just told.
We participated this year
in the Mississippi Book
Festival for the first time.
People from the National
Book Festival.
And so we're converging I guess
in Mississippi, but, again,
with state Centers for the
Book, there's one in every state
and we talk tonight at the
reception a little bit.
I'll have a roster
of the state centers.
And I hope that that's another
connection that if you haven't made,
you'll consider making
because we are,
as Todd said, in the same business.
We just come at it different ways.
And the more different ways that
we can approach it, the better.
Next, Matt Sironas
[assumed spelling],
Men with a Message Braille Program.
Let's give Matt a hand.
[ Applause ]
OK. Good afternoon.
Thank you for this honor, inviting
us to be here with you today.
If you can read, you can
learn to do anything.
This is something that the Men
with the Message Program
strongly believes in.
For the past 26 years, Delaware's
Department of Corrections
and the Division for the Visually
Impaired's Instructional Materials
and Resource Center has
made it their responsibility
to make written material accessible
in alternate formats for the blind
and severely impaired
Delawareans primarily K-12 students
that we serve.
Each request received is unique.
But there is a common goal and
that is to help the student,
young or old, to read and learn
with the hope of them wanting more.
Our program is stationed
in the James T. Vaughn Correctional
Center in Smyrna, Delaware.
And it's partner, the Division
for the Visually Impaired
in Wilmington, Delaware.
Our program began in 1989 with five
members and a part-time proctor
that focused on producing braille.
And they earned their certifications
in braille transcription
from the Library of Congress.
The program grew and as the number
of highly skilled men joining the
team increased, so did the number
of Library of Congress
certifications awarded to these men.
These certifications are not just
for braille transcription but also
for proof reading the braille codes
in the following formats: Literary,
math and science, also
known as Nemeth, and music.
We also developed workshops
that strengthened the skill sets
of our transcribers in the areas
of foreign language
and tactile graphics.
And as the program grew further,
the service of providing material
in large print was added.
And in later years we
offered ink and braille
on the same page line for line.
We found that this
format helped engage some
of our sighted family
members and their peers
with the braille reader's experience
with reading and learning.
Historically, hard copy was the
medium requested for our readers
and we still provide it in
that format to this day.
However, with the advancements
of technology and laptops,
accessible portable note
takers, IOS devices,
as they became more readily
available to students,
we received more requests
for reading material
to be accessed on mobile devices.
And so we continued to
adopt new practices.
No longer was it just about having
the written word in large translated
by our team, but by the device
and actions of the end user.
The trick for us, to get the
hard copy print into a format
that the device could understand,
read out loud, and have it sent
to a refreshable brain display
so that the student could read the
material tactually, which leads me
to say accessibility is not
a future, but a procedure.
I'm amazed at the level of attention
and care that goes to each request
that we serve, the pride that the
men take in their work, the proofing
and the quality control
measures that they have in place.
We do this to insure that the
reading material's not just
accessible but usable so
that the client can read
and interpret the information
the way the author intended it
to be read.
The participants in this program
have always strived for excellence
in their customer service.
They rise to the occasion to
perform above and beyond by learning
and embracing these emerging
technologies, adopting new methods
and procedures, mastering new
formatting codes and rules,
and monitoring and
training the new members
of the program while focusing on the
client who wants to read and learn.
Our current team has 12 full-time
inmate workers and their supervisor,
four -- including myself -- at the
Division for the Visually Impaired,
and several, several
hard working volunteers
who have devoted their countless
hours of their precious time
to help clients receive
their reading material.
As a result of our
practices, our blind
and visually impaired
clients have a better chance
of reaching their goals
because they continue to read.
In closing -- I know
we're short on time --
I would like to point out
that all of our program,
all it's accomplished
could not be possible today
without the pioneering
efforts and accomplishments
of Mrs. Anne Hitchcock who
we lost earlier this year.
In May of 1989, Anne
began to lead this program
until her retirement in 2010.
We miss her dearly.
And we're OK on time.
Thank you very much.
>> You have time.
>> That's OK.
If there's any questions if?
Or save them for later because?
>> You have a question over here.
>> So, do any of the men get
feedback from the target users?
>> Absolutely.
We have our -- we work at the
Division for the Visually Impaired
with the teachers or the
requester and, yes, we get feedback
and that's how we continue to evolve
or it may be alter future volumes
of the book that we're doing.
>> I have a question.
To what extent.
>> Let me give you.
Thank you.
>> How does -- oh, hello --
do the inmates who receive
these certifications go
on to get employment once
they're released and?
>> We've had people in
our program and, yes,
we've had someone leave the program
and they came to work with us
to continue to serve and
use those braille skills
that took years to obtain.
And we recently hopefully
having this opportunity again.
And for those who aren't
there, they --
so we have some members who
have been in that program
for many years within that room.
So, you know, we do our
best and they do their best.
They want to be there.
We've got people in that
program who've been there longer
than I've -- and I've been with
the agency 20 plus years, 22 years.
And they're still in that room.
And we've had people who have left
and wanted to help serve the blind
and visually impaired still.
So, yes.
>> How is electronic braille
changing the landscape
of what you do?
>> When I -- what I think I'm
hearing you say is that, you know,
historically, like I mentioned,
everything was on paper.
Now, our requests are, "I want to
read my book on my iPad or I want
to read it on my computer."
OK. We have now devices that sync
up to these laptops so we have
to make sure that the file that
we provide, either we download it,
we create it, or we have to
take something from scratch,
chop the spine off, and
run it through our scanners
and put all that together.
And sometimes they want both.
Sometimes they want to have
something that they can read
and something for their
mobile device
with the refreshable
braille display.
And it's always good because we've
had summer reading times, you know,
it's hot outside and those
batteries tend to fail.
So, we have some kids who
have the hard copy right there
in case the device
is low on batteries.
But with all this, our guys in
this maximum security prison,
they're not -- these computers
are not on the internet.
They are standalone.
It's difficult for us
to get things in there.
The trainings that Anne,
my colleague over here,
and I help provide them with,
the materials that we give them,
it is a tough battle, but you know
the guys are really embracing this.
It helps keep them in touch with
what's going on outside those walls.
It gives them an idea of the kinds
of material that's now being taught.
You know, math isn't
what it used to be.
And it's -- they're
learning themselves too
and they're having a really --
it's amazing seeing the
interest no matter what age.
I've got some braillist in there
that are -- that are seasoned.
And we brought in some devices.
This is how your books
are being read.
We have to learn new
ways of making them.
So, they're following new
recipes, they're embracing them.
We're happy with that.
But it's a lot of work.
Anymore? OK.
Well on time?
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
>> Well, it's a wide word
that we inhibit isn't it?
Next speaker is Shanti Shovashanka
[assumed spelling] National Resource
Center for Non-Formal
Education in Nepal.
Shanti? Thank you.
Let's give her a hand.
[ Applause ]
>> Good afternoon, everyone.
Namaste. I don't have any
PowerPoint presentation.
I'm just sharing my feeling and give
a brief introduction of our program.
I -- it's great to be
here in Washington, D.C.,
United States of America.
Such a big country from Nepal,
such a small country [laughing].
And representing our organization,
National Resource Center
for Non-Formal Education, NRC-NFE.
It's a great pleasure
for me, my friend Sheila,
and for our organization to
participate in this awards ceremony.
And I would like to express
heartfelt thanks to the Library
of Congress on behalf
of our organization
for providing us this
opportunity to deliver my remarks
and share our experience.
Really, it's a great honor
for us to be selected as one
of the best practices
honorees for the 2015 Library
of Congress Literacy Awards.
This has been very
encouraging reward for us.
We are very grateful to
the Library of Congress
for recognizing our effort in
the field of promoting literacy
and non-formal education through
community learning centers.
Now, I would like to briefly
share about our programs.
NRC-NFE, our organization, has
been working for the literacy
and non-formal education through
community learning centers
since its establishment in 1995.
Our major theme of the program is to
promote community learning centers
at a delivery mechanism of literacy
and non-formal education
programs at grass roots levels.
CLC means community
learning centers,
is a community based
organization managed and operated
by the community people
for the community people.
It is a multipurpose
organization which plans
and implements different education
as well as other need based programs
for the benefit of different
target groups of the community.
And it is continuously
providing learning opportunities
for the community people.
Realizing the value of the
CLCs for literacy promotion
and community development
at grass roots level,
CLC has become the
national program in Nepal
and there are 2,151 CLCs running
in the country at present.
Main function of our organization in
promoting Community Learning Center
and literacy is to work
as technical backstopping
which includes activities
like advocacy,
[inaudible] building
training programs,
developing teaching learning
materials and resource materials,
and design and implementing various
kinds of need based education
and other programs
for the communities.
We have been providing financial
support for various kinds
of literacy and non-formal education
programs for various target groups.
For example, basic
literacy, post-literacy,
vocational skill based literacy,
environmentally literacy, maternal
and child health literacy,
computer literacy, English language,
and many more skill based training
programs for youth and adults
and for out of school children
and school dropout children.
We have open school programs and
particularly, for literacy promotion
in the country, NRC-NFE has been
supporting the government literacy
campaign programs since 2008.
Its major role in the government
initiation was developing textbook
and supplementary materials based
on learning achievement
indicators defined and supporting
in the facilitators
training programs --
I mean teachers training programs.
Thousands of copies of
textbooks in Nepali language
and other local languages were
printed and distributed nationwide.
It also encouraged the CLCs to
work as likely implementing partner
for the Literate Nepal Mission,
that is literacy campaign.
Ninety percent of the target has
been achieved in [inaudible] so far.
Additionally, we have been
helping to strengthen the CLCs
and promoting them to develop as
lifelong learning center with some
as green sustainable centers.
We have deviled some CLCs as
mobile CLCs and developed them
as green sustainable centers.
This way our organization has been
working hard to promote literacy,
non-formal education,
continuing education
through Community Learning Centers.
And for this it is working
very closely with the Ministry
of Education particularly Non-Formal
Education Center and we feel
that we are successfully
heading to our mission.
To our mission we have been
supported by our particular donor,
National Federation
of UNESCO Associations
in Japan, NFUAJ, since 2002.
So, great thanks to NFUAJ for
providing continuous support
for the CLC project and also
for encouraging us to apply
for this International Literacy
Award and sending reference letter.
Our effort has been possible with
the support of NFUAJ [laughing].
We are thankful to our
organization and our boss [laughing]
for sending us to participate
in this event [laughing].
I believe this would be a good
learning opportunity for us.
Lastly, I would like to
thank Mr. John Y. Cole,
Chair of the 2015 Library of
Congress Literacy Award and Director
of Center of Book and Miss Jillian
for providing all the required help
in the way for [inaudible]
this event so far.
So, today, 27th, October 2015 would
be a very special and memorable day
for me, for my friend,
and for our organization.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Well, thank you
for those nice words.
And I must say I thank everyone here
for agreeing to -- several of you --
to make the trip and
it's been touch and go
for several of you to get here.
I know that.
But on every effort, I
mean you've made the effort
and I think your presence is
already making a huge difference.
Our next speaker is Karen Hart from
Picturebooks from South Africa,
while I'm speaking of
people who've made the trip.
Let's give her a hand.
[ Applause ]
>> So, again, I'm going
to say thank you
for the opportunity for being here.
It took me 18 hours
to get all the way
to Washington, D.C.
and it is an honor.
I'm sending photos back as I'm
going along with my family that's
at home that's really
supported this project.
And me being here today.
So, we had to do for
the Deaf community
in South Africa what
books couldn't do.
Books are extraordinary
things, but if you are a person
that doesn't have any language,
a book cannot tell you the story.
All you can do is imagine what is
happening in the pictures and make
up your own if you have language.
In South Africa, like many
other developing countries,
we have a problem with
most of our -- sorry --
most of our students get exposure
to language the very first time
when they're walk in to
school with our grade one.
This means that our teachers
are sitting with students
that have never had any
exposure to language.
And our government
expects our students
to follow exactly the
same curriculum
as our hearing students do.
But these are students
that have no language.
So, my journey became a journey
that involved many more people
and it was something that was
extremely unexpected for me.
I created this small
application and went
and visited my local Deaf school
knowing absolutely nothing
about sign language and knowing that
I know nothing, I went to the people
that I thought would
be able to help me
and explain how all of this worked.
Because I found out in South Africa,
our sign language was founded
by British Sign Language,
South African Sign Language,
English Sign Language and in
our other 11 official languages.
And it was like a tower
that was falling over
and no support for our community.
So, we had to go further and
see what we could do to create
for our Deaf community to learn
the best way that they could.
And we saw that a book
was not going to do that.
A paper book wasn't
going to do that.
But a digital book can
because in a digital book,
we can replace pictures
with animations.
And we can replace arrows
of how sign language would
work, with actual videos.
So, we could show students
what it really looks like.
Just a simple thing,
the sign for J is this.
If you don't understand what
that arrow means when you look
at that little image, you
could get the letter wrong.
That's just a letter.
That's just the alphabet.
We haven't even thought of words
and expressing ourselves
with sign language.
So, we had to look at another
way of presenting all of this.
And we ended up with using iPads.
And in a developing
countries, this was a stretch.
Everybody said, "IPads?
They're so expensive!
How can you do that?"
And we sad, well, we need the
absolute best device that we can
because we cannot afford
for this project to fail.
We cannot afford to worry about
the device that's not going
to achieve the goal that we have
to because we have one shot.
And we started knocking on doors
and we initially only got
funding for creating apps.
We didn't have iPads and we
took the stance, if we build it,
they will come [laughing].
And we created our first two apps
without having iPads in the school
and me having three lone iPads that
I would rent to the school and test
and see if it was working if
we presented it the best way.
And I've got a lot of
statistics that I put
in my keynote presentation that
I can quickly skip through.
I mean I'll show you what we built.
But before I skip through
to what we've built,
I just want to mention
a couple of things.
Ninety percent of our Deaf kids
cannot speak to their parents.
This means that these children
spend their whole lives living
in a very, very small world.
And when they do get to our schools,
they get exposure to sign language
but they also don't get any
exposure when they go home again.
So, that language is only
spoken in school time
or while they're in session.
Because most students
stay in hostiles.
So, there's very little
reinforcement at home
with sign language as well.
We don't have parental
involvement because a lot
of our parents are
uneducated themselves.
So, the only source of sign
language is at the school.
I'm going to skip through to
show you what we've built.
This is just a quote that I fond
and I think a lot of people think
that people who are
Deaf, "they've got eyes,
they can read, they can write."
but have you ever thought
of just the sound
of A. It can be an A. It can
be an R. And we've been exposed
to those sounds in utero.
We start hearing when we
are 26 weeks in utero.
We get exposure to our mom's voice
and language develops
from there onwards.
For a Deaf child, they
never get that exposure
to the auditory element of sound.
And we forget how important sound
and languages and the auditory part
of that to reading, to
understand how to read.
You have to hear it to know what it
sounds like to be able to read it.
So, when I started my journey,
I was one of those people.
I had no idea.
I didn't know that Deaf people
couldn't read and write.
I thought we're quickly going to
create an app, I'm going to put it
on the app store and I'm going to
move on and create my other books.
But the school entrapped
me, they entrapped my heart.
And they've created a space where
I think I can do my life's work.
These are some of the students at
Transylvania School for the Deaf.
They are the most spirited
people I've ever seen.
And don't ever think that a
Deaf school is a silent place.
These children have got joy
and laughter and exuberance
and you can see it in
them playing outside.
These are one of my
grade four students
that we tested the books on.
So, initially when we started out
with the books, we created books
for grade four and five students.
And my daughter who's hearing
was grade one at the time.
And we were testing that with her
reading levels to see where we were
on the scale of grade one, grade
four, between the reading and --
between the hearing and
non-hearing students.
And these students were struggling
with a grade one level book.
So much so that they had
almost no comprehension
of what they were reading if
we gave them a paper book.
But then we created these apps.
I can skip through all of this.
You'll see this is the first time
they had exposure to the iPads.
I literally went in with 30 iPads
that we put down in front of them
and they had never
seen the books before,
they'd never seen an iPad before.
And we showed them where the home
button was and we opened the apps
and they started exploring.
So much so that they found things
that I didn't think they would find.
They found things like pinching
in and pinching out [laughing].
And I should have known because
these kids are gesture based.
You know? They're going
to use their hands.
They're going to use their skills
to communicate and find things.
This is the book that we created.
And you'll see that the
book is in my home language
on the left side, in Afrikaans.
And then on this side it is in
English and that is accompanied
by South African Sign Language.
So, this is a trilingual
book that we have created.
We had to start with Afrikaans
because the school
initially was only Afrikaans
and used Afrikaans
based sign language.
But then South African Sign Language
became recognized by the government
and we had to transition from
Afrikaans based sign language
to English and South
African Sign Language.
So, we created the books in both of
the languages for the older students
and the new younger students.
So, I'm going to just play.
>> The Big Carrot.
>> And that's me [laughing].
My person that was supposed to
narrate got lost and couldn't come
to the day of the recording
so I had to do it.
And, but we started out
by creating a picture --
with animation introduction
of the characters.
>> The farmer.
The farmer's wife.
>> You can just make
it a little bit -- ?
>> They work very hard.
>> And then over here the sign
language interpreter is telling the
story in sign language, which
is a completely different syntax
to English syntax.
And the student can go back to that
and keep rewatching
it as they go along.
Those words, you'll see are
highlighted and if you touch them,
it shows you both the sign
plus the object or the person
or the action plus the
word underneath it,
plus the finger spelling
which is Deaf ABCs.
And we found that this was the most
effective way to make that link
between English and
sing language and create
that bilingual environment for
students to see all of the elements
at once and being able to go back
to it as many times as they needed.
We couldn't have this on an autoplay
where you could just start and play
through because that's what's
happening with their reading.
It's autoplay.
They'll read through it, but
there's no comprehension.
By presenting it in this way,
students could go at their own pace
and they could work through the book
and really absorb both
the sign language as well
as the finger spelling as
well as the text spelling.
And then make that connection
between the English syntax
and the sign language syntax.
Just a simple example, we would say,
"The man is walking in the street."
In sign language they would
say, "Man street walk."
So, when we have words in there like
"the" and "and" and "Up" and "wow!"
and "oops!"
those aren't words that
really exist in sign language
and when they see those things,
they get stuck and they don't want
to read because it's difficult
because they don't
understand what it means.
And they don't understand what
context that word is used in.
So, we had to place all of
that in context with a parallel
of sign language, with a
parallel of English next to it.
So, those were the
books that we created.
I'm proud to say that we created
this with a very, very small team.
We've had over 18,000 downloads
all over the world actually.
I'm surprised.
We've got some in Kazakhstan,
Russia, Bermuda, Jamaica, Australia.
It's everywhere.
And we've had a lot of interest
from the Pakistan government,
the New Zealand Ministry for
the Deaf to create more books
because this platform that
we've created, we can just slot
in the different sign
language and use the stories
that we've already created
and just put different text in
and different sign language videos.
And the students all over the
world can get access to it.
So, this is our little iDeaf
project that started just
as I couldn't walk away because
these students needed help.
Thank you so much for
this opportunity.
I don't know if I have the time.
[ Applause ]
>> You've used your time.
>> Thank you so much.
>> So much of this hits home in
the word that we do in the Center
for the Book as you can imagine.
We have two networks.
We have a network that includes all
of the states of the United States.
These are reading and
literacy promoters
that have come together often
in the state library but also
in other organizations
to help us do our work
of stimulating public
interest in books,
reading, literacy, and libraries.
But our second network
is of organizations,
non-profit organizations, that
already are involved in this work.
And it changes frequently
project by project.
It isn't quite -- the state
Centers for the Book have to apply
to renew every three years to make
certain that we can keep an eye
on how they're using the
Library of Congress's name.
This is what the Library tells
me so I keep an eye on them.
And -- but we do good work together.
But one of our groups that
we worked with before came
to visit us yesterday
quite coincidentally
with Karen's presentation and it's
the Literary Society for the Deaf.
And it's an organization
that started with Gallaudet
in Washington, D.C. and
they have regrouped.
And we lost them for
a little while and --
but we've agreed to do a project --
I mean a program with
them next April.
And so that's one of the things I'd
like to talk to you and to Karen
and to others about because
it's what makes, you know,
actually this category quite real.
When you see the people
who are doing the work
and you suddenly see a way
that one of us, you know,
can move in a new direction.
And so this is the kind of
goal I think that overall
that we should all be
thinking about as we learn
about each other's programs.
Our next speaker is Zev
Lowe from Worldreader
which is based in Barcelona, Spain.
Zev. Let's urge him on.
[ Applause ]
>> Thanks so much, John.
I'm so honored to be
here among all of you.
I also just flew here
from Barcelona yesterday,
but not quite as far
away as South Africa.
So, really quickly, Worldreader's
mission is to provide every child
and her family, particularly in
the global south, with the books
that they need in order
to improve their lives.
And we work digitally.
Since I think we're hardly alone
here in believing that it all starts
with a book, so that's what
I want to talk about first.
We've curated a large library
focused on the global south,
which for us at the moment we're
focusing on sub-Saharan Africa
and soon we're moving
into India as well.
But our Global Library has more than
28,000 book titles in 44 languages.
And here are just some
examples of the book titles.
These are sort of grown up
general sort of literary books.
There are also a lot
of children's books.
My favorite one here is Wimbo
Wa Matatu The Matatu Song.
Matatu's are mini buses in Kenya
that are their public
transportation.
And this is actually a bilingual
book that has a song that goes along
with it, which I like quite a bit.
Our books also include
textbooks and, as you can see,
these are not exactly textbooks
that you would find here
in the United States.
But for our readers
they're the textbooks
that are most useful
and immediate to them.
And, yeah, more sort of general
fiction for adults as well
as some books about STEM.
So, you know, we love books.
And we want to make these available
to as many people as possible.
And so, we work digitally
primarily in two different ways.
We have programs that are schools
and libraries using eReaders
like the Kindle, which in the
five years that we have been
in existence have come down
in price pretty dramatically.
And cell phones.
Turns out that 80% of the
world's population has access
to cell phones.
The Gate's Foundation says that more
people have access to cell phones
than have access to toothbrushes.
So, cell phones really
are absolutely everywhere.
And we make our books available
through basic sort of future phones
like those old Nokia brick phones.
And so here's a picture
of one of our schools
that is using our sort
of eReader program.
In these programs, we don't
just provide the digital books.
We also provide teacher training.
We provide periodic assessments
and we encourage the schools
in the training and
launch phase to make sure
that they are setting aside time
and creating community engagement
and basically insuring that
children will have safe spaces
in which they can read and spend
what we call time on task reading.
On cell phones, this is a
particularly nice picture just
because it shows one of our
cell phone users reading.
When the whole -- and you'll see
that the books that are popping
up for that particular
reader have to do with Ebola.
One of the things that
we didn't realize was
by making a giant library of
books available in the palm
of people's hands, health would
actually be one of the most sort
of sought after categories of books.
We see this among teenage
girls in Kenya
who all flock toward
reproductive health books.
And we saw this in particular
during the Ebola crisis in Liberia
where in a three month period, we
saw our users triple in Liberia.
We started to put up -- we
just digitized sort of CDC,
WHO materials, anything
that we could get out there,
about how Ebola really spreads.
You know, in what cases you
might actually be at risk
and in what cases you're
not at risk.
Just factual material.
And in that first month 60,000
people had read those materials.
So, we are still discovering
the potential
of this new medium ourselves.
But so far we're learning
quite a lot.
Here's a really cool story
that I just wanted to tell you.
We're working right now with Kenya
National Library Serves to scale
up our digital reading
program to every single one
of their 61 libraries, 61
public libraries nationwide.
Before our program, they had
mobile libraries that were brought
around by donkeys, which I've always
thought is a really cool idea.
But it turns out that it's
very complicated for librarians
to also manage to keep
a stable of donkeys.
The donkeys kept getting sick.
It was really expensive to
keep having to buy their feed
and in addition to librarian
duties, to haul donkey feed
over to the donkeys and feed them --
which is not something that I
actually thought about before.
But it turns out donkeys
are complicated.
So, then they went
to a different model
where they had the donkey carts
but they would rent the donkeys.
Well, it turns out that's
difficult too because donkeys tend
to be busy animals and the
people who own them have,
you know, lots of work for them.
So, you can't always get the
donkeys when you need the donkeys.
So, in providing the librarians with
digital books, this is one of them.
His name is Kelvin Guma
[assumed spelling].
His entire community now
refers to him as eReader,
which we think is kind of funny.
But he has a tote bag in which he
puts, you know, 20 or 30 eReaders
and then he sits on the
back of a motorcycle
or actually now he's
got his own scooter,
and goes out into rural communities
and does mobile library outreach
programs in little huts like these
as well as in tents
sometimes as well.
So, no more donkeys.
Sorry, donkeys.
This is a quote from UNESCO.
They released a report last year
called Reading in the Mobile Era,
which was really sort of a
groundbreaking study that they did
about mobile reading
through programs like ours.
And what they said was, "If every
person on the planet understood
that his or her mobile phone could
be transformed, easily and cheaply,
into a library brimming with books,
access to text would cease to be
such a daunting hurdle to literacy.
An estimated 6.8 billion people
would have access to books."
So, that's the quote that
I want to leave you with.
And I can't really tell you about
our work nearly as well as one
of our library users can and since
we're in the Library of Congress,
I thought it would only be fitting
to show you this really quick
video of one of our users.
>> Better kind of life
I was [inaudible].
But because [inaudible] it's
changed my mind and today I'm here.
I came from a poor family.
We couldn't afford the basics
[inaudible] even a lot of things.
I didn't have my own school.
All of us [inaudible] shoes.
We would share only one or
two books once in a while.
I lost my dad.
I lost my mom.
They had died of AIDs
[inaudible] yes.
I came to learn that I had only one
option in life [inaudible] digital.
That was one option.
Reading [inaudible].
I would read for hours
[inaudible] sense
of understanding about
life [inaudible].
I was able to go to the [inaudible].
And my teacher [inaudible].
Even much more than I was
[inaudible] more information.
The first time I had [inaudible]
that was my first encounter
with the eReader and [inaudible].
[Inaudible] a lot of material
that I couldn't find on the shelf.
Even in the [inaudible].
To [inaudible] in the
house, I read it.
As [inaudible] I passed the safety
information [inaudible] the school.
I'm very, very, very much excited
for students to use eReaders.
eReaders [inaudible]
access and a lot more books
than they have ever
seen [inaudible].
I have a passion for teaching.
I have a passion for
[inaudible] life.
And [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
>> Our final speaker will
be Sister Mary M. Buckley
and she represents a -- is she here?
A literacy education group in
the Dominican Republic and her --
I'm going to ask her to pronounce
the name of her organization
as it should be pronounced rather
than the way I would pronounce it.
Please, Sister.
Let's give her a hand.
[ Applause ]
>> I'm speaking for the Escuela
Santo Nino Jesus de Fe y Alegria
in Santo Domingo of
the Dominican Republic.
And I'm very very happy to be
here and I thank the Library
of Congress for this opportunity.
Actually, I'm standing in for
someone else who was standing
in for someone in the
Dominican Republic.
So, I'm a very last minute add-on.
But it was really important
to me that one of us be here
because I feel as if it's
an opportunity to speak
for some children who are
both invisible and voiceless.
And these are Haitian children
living in the Dominican Republic.
Ours in particular are in Santo
Domingo in what's called a Batey.
A Batey is like a Haitian ghetto.
Originally Haitians came to work
in the sugarcane plantations.
And when they were taken
over by the government,
the Haitian lost their job
and they couldn't return
to Haiti nor were they
accepted into Dominican society.
So, they really were just left to be
forgotten in these Batey situations.
Ours is called the Batey
Laturia [assumed spelling].
I am a Catholic sister, a member
of an international community called
the Society of the Holy Child Jesus.
And about 25 years ago, a few of
our sisters went to Santo Domingo
and they looked around to
see what needed to be done
and they were drawn to the
Haitians in this Batey.
And it all started with a container.
You know, one of those big
container -- structures.
And that became a library.
And little by little they began
to engage the children in learning
to read and trying to do
something also with the parents.
Now, these are the poorest
of the poor and they have
so many things working against them.
So, it was a pretty
up-hill situation.
But the container then
gradually became a school,
Holy Child Montessori School.
That's Escuela Santo
Nino Jesus in Spanish.
And the Montessori school now has
about two, maybe three buildings
at this point and about
450 children.
The children come at the
age of three and they move
on into the public school system
probably at the end of 4th grade.
And the idea of the
Montessori school is
to give the children the training,
the literacy, the discipline,
all that they need
in order to be able
to succeed in the public schools.
So, it really -- it's working.
As I said, it's up hill.
It's very hard work.
It also entails working
with the families.
In fact, just last year, two of
our sisters from Nigeria went
to the Dominican Republic, learned
enough Spanish to function --
they're still working at that --
but they now are working
with the women in the Batey.
And part of that work will
be literacy education.
So, it's a wonderful work.
The needs are enormous.
It's growing.
It also entails training teachers,
which is a rather aspect
of the whole endeavor.
Our community is about 165 years
old and we have a long tradition
of education, education
of children and of adults.
So, teacher training
is in our blood.
And our sisters there
have really been working
at training the Dominican people
to be effective teachers
in this Batey situation.
So, from a container to a Montessori
school, to teacher education,
to further work then with
the adults in the Batey.
That's been the trajectory
over these 25 years.
And that's us.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.